control of the house is also up for
grabs on Tuesday our latest Battleground
tracker poll shows Republicans favored
to win a majority but there are a lot of
close races including one in Virginia
involving a member of the January 6
committee Scott McFarland spent time
traveling in that state and now he's
here with us Scott good morning good to
see you and Nate good to see you as well
this is a race against Republican
candidate Jen kiggins an incumbent
Democrat Elaine Lauria and congresswoman
Loria has something unique to talk about
what she calls her effort to prevent
another attempted Insurrection and
attack on Democracy it's just unclear if
that's going to sway enough votes
at a farmer's market in Virginia Beach
there's one thing on voters Minds
that's that's unreal like in so many
congressional races inflation and
abortion rights are dominating the
debate between Democratic incumbent
congresswoman Elaine Lauria and
Republican Challenger Jen kiggins both
U.S Navy veterans I think a woman should
have a right to choice we are suffering
this year because of the failed policies
of the Joe Biden Administration except
this is a race and a campaign season
like no other Donald Trump maliciously
repeated this nonsense because Loria
isn't a typical incumbent she's one of
nine members of Congress who became
National figures leading the house
January 6 select committee our hearings
have shown the many ways in which
president Trump tried to stop the
peaceful transfer of power her opponent
slams Loria for focusing too much on the
investigation so I think it shows that
she's out of touch with this District
being on the committee is out of touch
so focusing on January 6 making that a
priority and using her celebrity on that
committee to do things like fundraise
and I just think it's out of touch with
what the voters of the second district
are really caring about right now Gloria
Strikes Back criticizing Higgins for
questioning Virginia's 2020 election
results so State President Biden won by
10 points is there any political Peril
to being a face of the January 6
Committee in one of these toss-up evenly
split districts honestly I don't care
the truth about it is is that the work
that the committee is doing is so
important being on the right side of
History getting to the facts look at
what time
the three of the other nine members of
this panel are going to be gone at the
end of the year two are retiring
congresswoman Liz Cheney as you recall
lost her primary in Wyoming this was a
wedge issue her service on the committee
and last night in Michigan Liz Cheney
who says she's going to defeat the
election deniers endorses a democrat in
Michigan yes there's a little jarring to
see that picture but she really is
standing up for what she believes in but
it's interesting when you talk to voters
intent emotions are so intense on both
sides everybody feels very strongly
about this election there we are in
Virginia Beach where they have strong
thoughts as you say but they bring up
inflation they bring up the grocery
prices they bring up the gas prices I
mentioned the January 6 committee
they're all familiar with it yeah but
that's not top of mind for them one
thing affects you today the other thing
may affect you down the line right it's
immediate versus long-term Scott it's
always good to have you in studio thank
you and a reminder the midterms are less
than one week away and will have full
coverage for you here on CBS starting at
8 pm Eastern on November 8th